[Musique]
salut c'est chaleureux
ça fait un moment que je voulais vous
testerez l'odeur de flight on en a déjà
parlé j'ai déjà pris en main il ya
quelques bons mois déjà parlé sur la
chaîne et là il est temps de pouvoir le
tester pour vous dire un peu ce que j'en
pense parce que c'est vrai que les
condyles et au nord se sont quand même
plutôt cool d'estelle aux nordistes avec
le gpu turbo qui est une vraie bombe
atomique
très clairement c'est pour moi le
smartphone android faire du moment sur
un peu compliqué à départager mais avec
le chu turbo c'est une vraie vraie vraie
tuerie est là le nom de flight on n'est
pas du tout dans la même catégorie on
est sur un smartphone à moins de 200
euros
néanmoins cette version du nord 9 en
version lite peut être intéressant dans
son affaire c'est qu'on va la tester on
va l'ouvrir on va regarder ce qui est à
l'intérieur on l'a testé le produit et
on va voir au final si vous devez
acheter un smartphone à moins de 100
euros est ce qu il fournit sur le
honneur de flight oui ou non on les bat
voici donc la boîte d'honneur de flight
joli packaging un peu bleu turquoise
plutôt pas mal
voilà dans son écrin de lumière voilà la
bête très léger très grand format
compact tient bien dans la main nous
avons de quoi ouvrir le tiroir de cartes
sim lead de démarrage rapide garantie ex
coque transparente en plastique
plastique rigide de protection qui va
venir se loger là c'est pas forcément
sera plus beau mais pour le coup ça a le
mérite d'être dedans et à moins de 200
euros
c'est plutôt bien adaptateur secteur
câble micro usb usb
on a la possibilité d'avoir soit deux
cartes sim soit une carte sim et une
carte microsd d'un point de vue purement
design en termes de prise en main je le
trouve plutôt pas mal qu'un vraiment
bien dans la main entre 14 en train
digital marche merveilleusement bien
vous avez un écran de 5,65 pouces c'est
une dalle ips et du lcd définition de
2160 par 1080 pixels résolution de 427
ppp et un ratio 18/9 il est fluide y
marche pas trop mal 1,5 kirin 959 octas
core cadencé jusqu'à 2 36 gigahertz l'ol
c'est un android 2.0 qui tombe sur un
mi-8 8.0 il y a une batterie à
l'intérieur de 3000 millions terreur
vous avez un double module photo à
l'avant 13 mégapixels + 2 mégapixels le
2e meilleur xl va sortir vraiment pour
les faits évoqués à l'arrière également
double module photo 13 plus de toujours
pour les faits évoqués un autofocus
rapide qu'on va les tester d'ici
quelques instants un design assez sobre
c'est le modèle ait donc on va pas non
plus lui demander des choses
extraordinaires dans les standards
actuels
rien de bien dingo bouton volume de ce
côté là pour l'allumer l'un micro usb
haut parleur mono prise jack ici votre
terroir de cartes sim
on n'est pas du tout sur un produit
révolutionnaire de l'écouter c'est un
smartphone qui coûtent moins de 200
euros
on va pas lui demander la ville si vous
voulez un smartphone d'entrée de gamme
si vous aimez la qualité au nord vous
pouvez y aller vraiment les yeux fermés
d'ailleurs s'il vous intéresse il un
tarif très intéressant kermesse et je
vous ai mis un lien en bas dans la
description le croquant voltz une vidéo
que j'ai fait sur le aux nordistes
vous pouvez bien évidemment zoomer kron
p soit c'est un grand classique sans les
formats 18/9 c'est à la fois bien et pas
bien parce qu'on va bouffer un petit peu
dans l'image mais bros
ça fonctionne à côté audio
il ya de la puissance ça va ça marche
les haut parleurs comme je vous disais
et jusque là
franchement l'audio sa marjaïya du son a
rien à lui reprocher de ce point de vue
là maintenant respecte le casque ça
marche
il ya du forum franchement il a rien à
dire le son est fort
j aurais tu es vraiment divinisé
choisissez place par une stabilisation
sur l'honneur d'y sacrifier plus
turboust avec c'est un truc de fou
mais là franchement je trouve que le son
est cool il ya du son le haut parleur
mono fait la sphère dans le casque ça
roule aussi en stéréo la qualité d'écran
est pas ma chance et d'un gars n'ont pas
un truc complètement fou alors
effectivement c'est une dali ps et du
lcd par des contrastes infinie on va pas
avoir des couleurs éclatantes comme sur
une dalle oled
néanmoins ça marche on n'a rien à lui
reprocher c'est un standard qui je vous
dis une fois de plus pour moins de 200
euros
c'est plutôt cool bon maintenant on va
aller voir ce qui vaut du côté de la
photo et de la vidéo
alors la question qui se pose souvent
que ces appareils c est ce qu ils sont
cools interne de photos vidéos là on est
sur le capteur arrière sur 13 mégapixels
en terme de vidéo on va faire de 38 est
aux alentours voir ce que ça dit
également au niveau de la photo est ce
que le résultat est bien pas bien et
pour l'instant à regarder uniquement sur
la caméra arrière
l'aja puis la halle points c'est bien
d'appui a coûté ça devient plus claire
sala réagi très rapidement par contre là
ça ne fait le point immédiatement
c'est pas mal luminosité
a vous de me dire un commentaire si ça
marche ou pas et qu'en est il des photos
on en passant test vidéo sur les caméras
devant up de ce que je vois là ça va pas
trop mal à y avait de reconnaissance
divisé à tout à l'heure
l'aja mode beauty failles actives et
embellissement degré l'embellissement
way éviter trop de s'embellir strict
artificielle ça vous lis la peau c'est
globalement pas terrible là je le mets 0
comme ça je désactive bon l'image comme
ça à l'air pas mal
on est mois d'août il fut une charte
possible avec un soleil a complètement
ouf à côté salaire quand même pas trop
trop dégueu nouveau de la gestion
physique et il ya le délire là c'est pas
complètement dingue
[Musique]
je trouve que le rendu quand même et pas
trop mal ça c'était en selle filles et
pas sur saturé c'est pas trop mal
exposés ça va ça serait même tête de
vainqueur non je trouve que franchement
de résultat et pas mal pas mal le point
s'est fait à côté pas sur la fleur de
foot et j'étais extrêmement près donc
bon c'est un peu plus compliqué à faire
ouais voilà c'est beaucoup trop près là
par contre on voit que le point ou bien
fait là dessus ça marche ça fonctionne
la très bien je trouve que c'est assez
net on a vachement de on a vachement de
détails sur l'image je trouve ça
vraiment super bien pour là aussi
là on à dia les petits poils sur la
fleur vraiment bien dans le détail il
alors là effectivement il ya beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de lumière et j'avais
fait le point par ici ça l'a bien repris
ça a bien marché
ouais aussi beaucoup beaucoup de détails
là pas mal de détails si j'avais
vraiment viser effectivement ici bien et
là par contre ça n'avait pas fait c'est
complètement surexposé mais bon c'était
le premier essai c'est pas anormal test
photo vidéo franchement plutôt réussie
se trouve que le résultat est là c'est à
dire que lorsque vous êtes dans les
conditions où il ya beaucoup de lumière
où il ya vraiment une forte lumière
ça marche ça vous captez le détail ça
sent la caméra de celles ci ou sur la
caméra arrière donc là dessus paluku
déception quand vous arriverez de
luminosité ça rajoute un peu de bruit
mais ça c'est pas complètement anormal
une fois de plus on est aussi sur un
smartphone qui coûte quand même moins de
100 euros
on en a pour son argent si on veut tout
de suite quelque chose de top en terme
de photos de vidéos il fallait beaucoup
beaucoup plus haut il rajouté beaucoup
beaucoup d'argent
vous allez faire x 3 x 4 pour l'instant
qu'ils sont vraiment top mais top de
chez top en photo / du smartphone une
fois de plus ça reste un smartphone
c'est pas un appareil photo voilà il
faut pas non plus il aurait des miracles
mais poterie le au nord de flight en
photo vidéo il remplit franchement la
fonction en terme de jeu c'est plutôt
pas mal après ça dépend effectivement du
jeu vous avez installé il ya des jeux
qui vont être plus grand que d'autres
pour des jeux qu'ils n'ont pas trop de
ressources
ça marche c'est parfaitement bien la
faire peut-être le point un peu négatif
ces catalans c'est un petit peu à
chauffer de l'eau côté bo pas trop lui
en demander
pour moi le test de l'écran et réussi le
test audio et super la puissance pourra
pas lui en demander
mais ça marche très très bien pour des
applications classiques et même des jeux
pas trop gourmands
ça fonctionne vous serez pas déçus la
photo est ce que vous avez la lumière ça
marche très très bien en fait de
luminosité c'est moins bien ça rajoute
du oui mais bon une fois de plus il a
moins de 200 euros va pas trop en
demander
le design est pas majorettes
révolutionnaire pour moi sur un
smartphone à moins de 100 euros
c'est vraiment un excellent rapport
qualité prix
dites moi ce que vous en pensez comment
est ce que vous trouvez ce nom de flight
est ce que vous l'avez déjà est ce que
vous pourriez avoir est ce qu'il fout
fait de l'oeil et est ce que pourrait
vous tentez vous marquez bien évidemment
tout ça en commentaire moi je vous dis
une fois de plus si vous avez un budget
d'au moins 200 euros si vous aimez la
marque au nord si design vous plaît vous
pouvez franchement y aller parce que en
termes de rapport qualité prix il est
vraiment excellent une fois de plus vous
aviez un lien dans la description pour
aller prendre directement chez kermesse
n'hésitez pas à le faire
mark et moi bien évidemment tous vos
commentaires questions interrogations
suggestions directement va vous invite à
mener ces deux jolies pouces reçoit
pareil toujours plus de take 2 tests de
produits il ya plein de choses qui vont
arriver nombreux à s'être connectés
regardez moi y'a plein de quatre essais
derrière être hyper cool et on a de la
brosse à dents électrique de chez audi
on a le 1008 qu'on va tester d'ici
quelques jours
eco2 amazon le drone à 9,6 fin il ya pas
mal de petits trucs à des objectifs
offert des photos des vidéos donc à pas
mal de trucs cool donc restez connectés
wahaha
merci à vous d'être toujours plus
nombreuse toujours plus nombreux je vous
dire très bientôt et prenez soin de vous
je vous embrasse et à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]